[Music]
and we're white again which is nice
e4
okay
um
proceed at your own risk as they say
okay d4
now this is some sort of scandy i mean i
guess this is not that bad is this candy
with a6
okay well our uh strategy doesn't change
we play this leica scandy thank you blm
w e for the prime we take it
and okay
we have a scandy with the move d4
already made
so we just go knight c3 and we play this
just like one would a regular scandy
okay so one little subtlety here um i
feel like
black's idea might be to go b5
and we can always meet b5 with the move
a4 you guys already know this from a
previous game the move b5 can often be
met with a4 that softens up the
queenside pawn structure
but you can also if you want you can
play bishop c4 to get the bishop
developed
before black has a chance to play b5
it also sets a trap if bishop c4 b5
there is a crushing tactical idea thank
you kaisers
let's go for it
and let's hope for b5 that's a pretty
common mistake i would say at this level
the best move here of course is okay
knight c6
that's another slightly weird move
because
it potentially walks into d5 now d5
would be a a temptation but in my
opinion not the greatest move
why is d5 not as effective as it might
appear well two reasons first of all it
blocks the bishop you know then one
might ask why did we get the bishop out
in the first place
the second reason is that when you push
a pawn it weakens the square and the
knight can just jump out to e5 so
just develop knight f3
and bishop g4 here is of course
a blunder due to bishop takes f7 check
which is missed
um but not knight g5 by the way not
knight g5 here that does lead to a draw
funnily enough but not to a win no we
want to take on f7 first
and that's gonna hurt although it's not
as bad as this blunder usually is
because yes the d4 pawn is gonna be
hanging in the end
obviously
it goes without saying that it's still
worth going for this because the king
loses castling rights and the whole king
side is destroyed
but black technically is not losing a
pawn here
oh yeah i'll show the draft of the game
knight f6 that's a good move
that's a good little intermezzo but we
need to stay energetic in our
approach here i said that the queen
should be the supporting actress but
oftentimes the caveat to that is when
there's a knight involved because the
queen and the knight are as you know the
strongest tandem in all of chess and so
here a particular move comes to mind
that might violate the idea of the queen
attacking from behind the front lines
but in this particular instance the move
queen e6 comes to mind because the queen
has a nice passageway to f7
does that make sense so we go queen e6
here
despite the fact
that we allow yeah we do allow knight
takes d4 with tempo but i don't care
because the queen is going to f7 anyway
and then we're gonna castle and try to
get a rook to d1 real fast
now are we gonna play queen f7 if we're
not forced to maybe maybe not
but okay here we're compelled to play
queen f7 check
and now a very important moment after
king d7 black is threatening knight
takes c2
do we need to bend over backwards to
defend that pawn absolutely not so as
i've already said what's the best move
in this position
it's the best move it's also the
simplest move it has a certain elegance
to it we just castle we castle out of
the fork and we prepare the move rook d1
so knight takes c2 is completely out of
the question here due to rook d one
check with a skewer
and
okay king it is good but it doesn't
address the fundamental issue
now whenever you play rook d1 in a
position like this you have to be very
careful about one thing which is that
uh because the back rank is weak you
need to make sure you're accounting for
all the discoveries
rook d1 there is a very tricky move
knight e2 check
is 92 check what's up simon is 92 check
actually dangerous
the idea being that if we take the
knight we get checkmated on d1
well the answer is no because we can
just move our king we can move our king
to f1
we're attacking black's queen and the
queen and the rook is being defended
sorry
yeah the rook is being defended by the
knight so yes it is safe to play knight
to play rook d1
and this is exactly what happens
he got excited at this tactic
now king h1 working f1 it really doesn't
matter both moves win but king f1 is
better because it approaches the knight
with the king
and now the game is over
now the game is over
my prediction is okay well that gives up
the queen
we will take that thank you very much
and we will take that thank you very
much
okay now again fastest way now the
scanning not really not working out for
our opponents what's the best way to to
go about converting this quickly
what's the what's the sort of most
clinical most surgical way well we don't
have our pieces out right we don't have
all of our pieces out
so
you don't need to do anything crazy 94
is a is a fancy move i idea being knight
takes e4 queen e8 checkmate good on you
for finding that but let's just get our
pieces out bishop f4 rook do you wanna
notice my emphasis all the time on
completing your development when
possible not always not that doesn't
mean every single piece has to come out
or or you're screwed
but it does mean particularly when
you're converting an advantage i think a
lot of people just sort of forget that
they have other pieces yeah even though
you're up with queen
that doesn't mean
your other pieces are all of a sudden
not important anymore
hitchstar thank you for the sub
yeah queen c4 is possible here but i
really want to make this a matter of
principle get all of your pieces into
the game
rook d1
russian this is like russian school of
chess and now i assure you everything is
going to be a lot easier well king c7
that's a free pawn and not just a free
pawn but it creates potential mating
squares on b6 and b8
okay rook c8 fine
and you know here uh probably the best
move is to drop the queen back to c4 and
pin yourself
because
well you could play knight e6
but if you play
funny thing after knight e6 is that the
queen on f7 is just sort of trapped
and you're gonna have a hard time
bringing it back
does it make sense like why i'm saying
queen c4 it looks like an awkward move
but you're actually just you're
assembling the pieces on the queen side
ultimately
you're you're assem and there's also a
discover check on the rook so the pin is
not dangerous first of all you're
threatening discover check
um and king v8 is bishop a7 check and
second of all you're just getting your
queen closer to
the spot it needs to be to deliver
checkmate
but yeah bishop now we can play bishop
b6 check this is the simple discovery
after king b8 uh it just occurred to me
that we have a very very pretty
checkmate we don't even need to play
bishop a7 check we have a checkmate this
is all about just looking for a better
move even if you see a good one
and
to see the checkmate you have to notice
the bishop on b6 and notice that it's
part of a larger pattern that larger
pattern is the
backrank man of d8
boom
and that's game ladies and gentlemen
now i guess one of the limitations of
the speedrun is kind of on full display
here which is that
i end up you know winning a lot of these
games just straight out of the opening
but i would argue that most of you guys
should be able to do this what i just
did
against this kind of opening play
there's absolutely nothing i did in this
game that's even remotely
crazy every move was natural and this
time i mean it honestly like sometimes i
say that and then i know deep inside
that some of my moves were advanced but
here every move was very natural
that's the one thousand dollar game
thank you fiesty hokage for the sub
yeah so by the way the the proper way to
continue here is b5 this is a legitimate
opening a6b5 is the same georgia it's
not that bad
this opening is not as bad as people
think it is in fact famously anatoly
karpov lost a game here a classical game
to a british uh late british grand
master named tony miles who was very
strong he was known for playing offbeat
openings and this pissed car pop off he
complained to the organizer he got
outplayed karpov got outplayed
um this is yeah it's not like white is
winning here white is much better but
it's not so easy to prove like a huge
advantage
well that's not true vladimir if you
solve your tactics you'd see bishop f7
okay so by the way yeah knight c6 just
exacerbates the problem
the reason uh knight g5 is just a draw
is that after bishop takes d1 bishop f7
check black has the d7 square and you
can repeat moves you can repeat moves
with bishop e6 and bishop
f7 and if king d6 then you get mated
with knight c4
so
and after bishop f7 like the game is
already basically over here i mean with
the king being as weak as it is and not
able to castle
it's just it's just not possible to
defend this
um if you want to see the karpov game
shirts it's it's actually a complicated
game i don't necessarily like going
through games really really quickly
uh because you miss their their subtlety
but i will show you i'll make an
exception
so this is the european
team championship 1980 karpov was 27 25
miles is 25 45 is a huge upset
yeah miles died quite young when he was
a very impressive
gm yeah so here we go this is german
german annotations e4 a6
um very
astute psychological decision so karpov
plays this pretty normally knight f6 is
another very provocative move and
apparently here the best line is to go
e5 and knight g5 and black is already in
big trouble but this is not karpov style
this is not sorry yeah this is not
karpov style
karpov decides to play it a little bit
slower queen e2
and miles goes c5 another crazy move
just pandemonium on the board
but eventually they get kind of a
sicilian type position and again this is
not in karpov style white is much much
better but this is
quite double-sided this is very
double-edged
and here karpov goes for the wrong plan
he goes c4
trying to get stuff going on the queen
side on passant
and he kind of forgets that he weakens
the b4 square now miles gets a knight on
this outpost
forcing karpov to trade black is the two
bishops now
again in this position karpov had to go
knight five and play aggressively but
instead he goes he continues to trade
now he goes knight g5 but it's a little
bit too late h6 and there's no
real initiative
karpov gives a check and goes bishop b1
obviously hoping for this kind of
checkmate miles just drops his bishop
back
and at this point black is already
better like black's got the two bishops
there's a weak pawn on b2
karpov keeps trying to make one move
threats and they fail he blunders upon
queen takes p2
attacking the rook so there's no knight
discovery
rookie one another blunder walking right
into queen takes e5 and again karpov
just completely forgot that the rook is
gonna hang if he moves his knight away
and
miles forces a queen trade in a very
nice way
that's it i mean he wins the end game
he wins the pawn up end game
he just crushes him actually it's not
even close
just wins another pawn and car part
resigned here two pawns down nothing to
play for
yeah karpov was rarely
defeated like this i mean it was just
like
boom
then i think the story is that karpov
complained to the organizer afterwards
but it was disrespectful but
what can you possibly say
but he was definitely angry
yeah this would be like if this happened
today with magnus
this would be in the news for weeks like
if this happened in a tournament where
magnus faced e4 a6 or h6 and lost
this would like never leave or the bomb
cloud or something like that
no no disrespectful that miles played a6
but
it's not disrespecting you play whatever
the hell you want
yeah so basically after there's not much
to analyze here i mean queen e6 is just
an important move but that's basically
it we give a check we castle and
inevitably we put a rook on d1 of course
black accelerated the defeat by playing
92 check the movie e5 here probably
keeps black in the game
the longest
but still we can play bishop e3 we can
consider playing f4 later to undermine
the knight on d4
well no knight f7 our queen is hanging
no no no no knight f7 doesn't work our
queen is hanging
and we have we have to move our queen
yeah that was great
um oh i have a good question before i go
question is
can you explain the idea behind these
types of openings that lose tons of
tempe how does black ops equalize
that's a very hard question to answer
because it's complicated
so how does this open it like why is
this okay for black
well first of all i think it's important
to realize that
it's not actually tons of tempi
it's just like one and a half right
white's developed and knight and y can
develop the other night
and the the zen behind this
line is that black is going to get
a major clamp on the center because
white is missing the e pawn
if you follow the main line here and i'm
gonna approximate i don't actually know
what the main line is exactly
but basically
okay bishop f5 i think is the move here
essentially if you follow the main line
what you're gonna end up seeing is that
black has created a major bind
on the d5 square
and one would argue like the scandy
player would argue that it's actually
worth spending these tempe at the start
to get this kind of an incredibly solid
structure where
white will have a very hard time
punishing black for the loss of tempe
because white doesn't have too much
mobility in the center the skinny really
changes the nature of the center
partially in black's favor
because if you think about it there
aren't a lot of openings where the epon
is traded early
i know that that sounds like a weird
statement like if you think about the
sicilian
or the perk
or
the karo khan and the karo khan mainline
white goes e5
in the french
white can also go e5 and in the in the
mainline french black doesn't really
want to take on e4 although that is a
rubenstein variation a lot of defensive
variations try to trade white's e-pawn
that's what they a lot of them have in
common the rubenstein variation of the
french and these defenses and openings
are not the best but they are very solid
the alakan another opening that trades
the e-pawn
boom in the main line or at least in
most of the lines the e pawn is traded
um let me think about it
and that's not the only one
there there are the petrov the petrov is
another defensive opening
that tries to get white sea pawn so the
fact that you get the c-bond makes it
harder for white to
get mobility in the center
and and it's a set of openings that
attempt to do that
i hope that helps you conceptualize this
a little bit
have a great night everybody i'll see
you guys soon
[Music]